Apple's new 15-inch MacBook Air is
everything I've ever dreamed of in a
laptop and I've actually been enjoying
it so much that I've considered
replacing my current 16-inch M1 Max
MacBook Pro at home for the new 15-inch
air but unfortunately there are three
reasons why I just can't do it but
before I get into explaining them I've
got to talk about why this new air is
just so dang tempting now of course the
15-inch MacBook Air is a really simple
product it's the 13 inch with the M2
Chip but bigger for two hundred dollars
more pretty simple right well not really
because there are a lot of little
upgrades beneath the surface that you
probably didn't think of and while some
of these seem simple they're actually a
pretty big deal in terms of everyday
usability the first thing I want to
mention is that the large 15 inch size
combined with the very thin design makes
this MacBook feel like like no other
MacBook in history it just doesn't seem
real to be holding something with such a
big display but it feels light and
insanely thin this MacBook is probably
the first one that would instantly blow
the mind of anyone used to using Windows
laptops because when you open the lid
and take a look at how thin the bottom
portion of it is it just doesn't seem to
make any sense that Apple packed this
much performance and battery life into
that little amount of space it'll blow
their minds even more when they see that
the size of the entire motherboard is
just slightly larger than the palm of a
hand which basically shows Apple's
dominance in the laptop Market
especially since this thing runs with no
fans at all but in terms of how this
differs compared to the 13 inch model
you get a very large track pad with tons
of room for multi-finger gestures and
making those long drag and drops without
having to lift your fingers the keyboard
has also been perfected over the last
couple of years no longer having those
terrible butterfly key failures the new
magic keyboard feels great and has
proven to be greatly reliable but the
big new standout feature is the 15.3
inch display which looks massive when
compared with the 13 inch and it truly
does show you more content on the screen
like when you're web browsing but
especially when you're trying to
multitask with multiple open Windows the
13-inch display just doesn't cut it when
you're trying to multitask with two
pages open at once side by side it's
just not big enough for a convenient
experience and the 15 inch air finally
delivers that but there are actually
some bonus features from that new
15-inch display that you probably
haven't thought about including
perspective even though the bezel size
is the same between the 13 and 15 inch
models the 15 inch air actually seems to
have thinner bezels because the size of
the display is so much bigger in
comparison so the bezels feel Slimmer
even though they're physically the same
on top of that literally we have the
notch which once again seems smaller
because the width of the display is
larger so the notch seems to take up
less room now this might not seem like a
big deal but because the notch is built
into the menu bar the 13-inch models
limited size actually makes it so some
of your open menu bar apps Disappear
Completely which is extremely annoying
with the 15 inch the added amount of
space allows for more text and apps at
the top which is a real world benefit
nobody talks about so honestly for just
200 more I'd say that the larger 15 inch
display is definitely worth it but
that's actually not all you're getting
for that extra 200 bucks right off the
bat the 15 inch air comes with the
upgraded 10 core GPU at the base price
giving you anywhere between 15 to 20
percent more graphics performance for
free so the difference is actually only
a hundred dollars if you were to get the
13 inch and upgrade anyway and then on
top of that the 15 inch model gets the
35 watt dual USBC charger for free in
the box also a 20 value so that brings
the difference to only 80 bucks between
the two so with that said it's pretty
clear that the 15 inch MacBook Air is
the best value Mac I've ever seen the
first time I heard this speaker
comparison between the 13 and 15 inch
models I was instantly Blown Away by how
good the speakers sound on the new 15.
right away you can notice that it has a
fullness to it encompassing all all of
the frequency ranges and putting them
together while also being able to
discern the highs from the mids and lows
very easily just listen
[Music]
bring me back to where we started
the speakers on the 13-inch seem like
it's mostly just highs in comparison
which is odd because it was already
destroying the speakers of basically all
other Windows laptops out there and the
15 inch is another big step on top of
that and this right here is very
important to me because when I watch
YouTube or other content on my MacBook I
don't want to go and have to grab my
earpods I just want to turn it on right
away and have it sound amazing so Bravo
to Apple for upgrading the speakers on
the 15 inch now getting into the hidden
performance differences even though the
13 and 15 both have identical eight core
CPUs the 15 inch model is actually six
percent faster when Under full load for
10 minutes in the cinebench R23 stress
test that's only because the 15 inch has
a larger metal chassis that dissipates
heat better than this smaller 13 inch
therefore being able to keep the M2 Chip
at higher clock speeds for longer before
having to slow it down to maintain cool
temperatures now even though the 15 inch
model performs better it still suffers
from that issue of not having a fan if
you're doing really intense work for
example we compared it to the 14 inch M2
Pro MacBook Pro and even though that
machine is only 24 faster in CPU and 60
faster in GPU performance the 15 inch
air took a huge 2.3 times longer to
finish the test due to Thermal
throttling and that point right there
finally brings me to the three reasons
why I just can't get myself to sell my
16-inch M1 Max MacBook Pro and buy the
new 15-inch air the first one is the
fact that Apple just released their new
game porting toolkit which means that I
can actually play the game that I've
wanted to play on my current MacBook
which is Diablo 4. just look at Andrew's
side running it at 60fps on the same M1
Max MacBook Pro that I have which is
perfect the M2 air obviously performs
much worse in terms of graphics
performance and the fanless design
wouldn't be able to handle long gaming
sessions without slowing down the
performance even more so because of that
the 15 inch air won't cut it as for the
second reason it's gonna be really
really hard to give up that xdr display
on the 16 inch because it truly does
give it really good contrast ratios and
makes the colors pop much more for
watching HDR content and movies but even
more than that it has 120 hertz Pro
motion technology which makes web
browsing super super smooth just look at
the difference in this slow motion clip
on top of that it allows you to get over
60 FPS while gaming all the way up to
112 20 while of course 60 is the hard
limit on the 15 inch air and then
finally I found that I actually used my
HDMI and SD card slot over this past
year more often than I thought and I
recently purchased a digital camera so I
started using the SD card slot much more
often for editing the photos so it's
been very convenient so for those three
reasons I don't think I could make the
switch to the 15 inch air but for people
who don't necessarily care enough about
those things to spend the extra cash the
new 15-inch air is the best value
MacBook ever made at least in my opinion
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and be sure to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
thank you